- man in London has what he describes as
very good news it's about his presidents
first phone call with Prime Minister
Boris Johnson the fight against the
covert 19 coronavirus was of course a
focus but so too was the friendship
between Britain and China Prime Minister
I told President
he loves China and he want to work with
China his administration to elevate
relationship to a new level it's a very
good composition and it really said not
only set a tone but also said they knew
interaction for China UK relations at
the critical moment nothing's more
critical right now than containing the
corona virus epidemic today it claimed
the life of another top doctor in the
Chinese city at its epicenter Lucy Ming
was the director of a hospital in Wuhan
the Ambassador can't yet say if the
crisis has reached its peak but he
pointed to positive signs it is first
time daddy confirmed cases were brought
down to less than 2,000 and the deaths
cases of brought down to less than 100
and confirmed cases outside who they
were brought down less than 100 that
shows that a quarantine effort measures
are taking very good effect he defended
the authorities from allegations of
being slow to respond and of cover-up
The Ambassadors also hopeful Britain
will scrap travel advice to its
Nationals to leave China our measures
are making progress
I show him positive in fact and they
produce
I think British government advises they
are going to make adjustment according
to a situation in China in the rare
phone call with a British prime minister
president she spoke of his appreciation
for a message of support he received
from the Queen Boris
Johnson also offered extra help this is
a relationship both sides seem keen to
nurture away from the coronavirus - we
know that once UK leaves you you will
you know have a new free trade agreement
with China and we're open to that the
prospect of such a deal has doubtless
been helped by a UK decision to defy us
pressure over its policy on China the
Prime Minister chose not to block the
Chinese firm Huawei from Britain's next
generation 5g network
despite security concerns it's a gamble
that won't have gone unnoticed by
China's all-powerful president Deborah
Haynes Sky News